i am a freestyle rapper which you all
entirely agree with you're like yeah no
you're gonna freestyle we know britain's
main exports freestyle rap and baking
shows those are the two things
we do really well freestyle rap is rap
that's made up on the spot it's not
written it's not prepared it's not
rehearsed it requires you lovely people
to start thinking of words topics or
phrases you would like to hear a rap
about what would you guys like a rap
about
you say gordon ramsay
can you like lift your hat if i wanna
check you're not him
it's the type of thing he would do he
would come to a show and shout his own
name out gordon ramsay gordon right for
those who don't know he's a very angry
british chef he says things that i
cannot say because there are children
around the edges of the audience gordon
ramsay is our first suggestion if you
are stood along this
freeway passageway sidewalk that's what
you call it yet in england we call it
pavement i apologize i'm picking up the
lingo if you're over here what would you
like a rap about
pardon
paper clip thank you very much yes
lovely paper clip gordon ramsay the rest
of you it's your fault that we've got
paperclip as the second rap topic you
could have said anything that lady was
like no stationery
let's come
to the back if you're at the back of the
horseshoe what would you like a rap
about
i beg your pardon that was a
i was like that is a very very small
voice what was it fire
yeah don't shout that in a crowded
environment kid
fire
paper clips gordon ramsay um let's come
hey people who weren't invited but here
anyway i'm i'm glad you're here look at
all these nerds you're the real people
right this is my crowd to wait what were
you about to shout
brexit
go away leave security remove this
person
brexit what about brexit brexit is a
multifaceted affair by which i mean it's
a massive balls up what
no no no you can't shout it and then be
like i don't actually know what i was
talking about i'm sorry
someone can help you out something
specific about brexit
i love this pose by the way this is my
favorite
pose it's like half rock star half lady
shaving her legs who knows
we'll just do brexit that's fine i like
your hat let's get our final suggestion
this can come from anywhere but it has
to yes what
oh that wasn't a suggestion that was
just someone strolling past
getting confused let's get one final
suggestion it has to be the best one of
them all what's it gonna be
toothpick
toothpick lovely stuff do you use
toothpick sir
no okay
i'm so i was i was a bit worried i'd say
that and you would just show me a
mouthful of gums and i'd be like that's
tragic so so we got toothpick we got
brexit we've got fire we've got paper
clips and we've got gordon ramsay and
we've got a perfectly timed helicopter
this then lovely people of las vegas new
york who knows where we are this is a
freestyle that's a wrap made up on the
spot and it goes something like this
let's drop that beat to remind you the
suggestions paper clip that's my
favorite toothpick gordon ramsay fire
and what was our other one that we got
brexit how could we forget
jen i still have flashbacks to that day
so this is what we're going to do a
three-star app and it's not going to be
anywhere near as atrociously bad as
you're expecting it to be cool
hopping on the beat yeah respect it
check it like five years ago we were
voting for brexit people like pu we hate
the eu they genuinely voted i can't
believe they do like 51 to 49
i was like this ain't gonna end well
then they presented the whole way
forward it was kind of hard a hard
brexit oh my god i was really worried we
had the fuel shortages if you watched
the british news they reported this we
had the man with the crazy blonde hair
boris johnson if you're not aware but he
was in there down in downing street
right to the microphone he's like blah
blah blah watch this when it's at home
i'm confused i've got no plan weird
blonde hair like a more familiar man you
see him over here and i understand he
gets angry in the restaurant that's
gordon ramsey with his blonde locks
sweaty red forehead he goes to the
kitchen he starts to forage he's like
this ain't great it's not a good time i
looked inside your fridge it's just
dripping with grime all the horrible
rust all the horrible moulds need to
throw your chef right out into the cold
i know that's not his accent i can't do
it properly it's like when americans try
to do cockney it doesn't work you should
stick to your own accent shouting out
toothpick what like something for a
little olive yeah you throw the devil
horns yeah and i acknowledge a toothpick
put it in your mouth and you arrive
there you look like a staten island taxi
driver when you're rocking a long bit of
wood you get a bit of meat in your molar
it's understood pretty good with the
reach you can excavate the teeth and if
there's no toothpick you can just seize
the nearest thing there's so many long
cylindrical and metal that's a piece of
stationary i'm getting over there and
then i let it slip between my molars and
my canines i use a paperclip no need for
a4 or legal size paperclips yeah i'll
just put it inside and if you want to
make sure that it's sterilized then from
your back pocket you can provide a
little lighter flip the zika or the bic
and then the flame comes out and that's
how we spit i know my man is shouted
over there must admire in the crowded
area he just screamed out fire
you